so would you have called the serious
black uh doggy instead of padfoot
yes yeah
i wouldn't call them poochie
but when it comes to fantastic beasts
and where to find them as it turns out
the answer is the three dollar dvd bin
at best buy with that in mind let's try
to imagine some of the other harry
potter spin-offs that we want to see on
the big and small screens
nina what are some of the other harry
potter spin-offs you'd like to see
well first bran i'm really glad you
took the opportunity to dunk on
fantastic beasts because i
made it halfway through the first movie
and just gave up and i can't even bring
myself to watch the second one knowing
what i know about i saw both in theater
oh my god one of them what was for work
yeah
i am
i
move
the no match thing really threw me a lot
i couldn't listen to them saying no
madge that many times because it sounds
so stupid they couldn't come up with
another word yeah anything imaginative
yeah and then i heard about the
definitely hallows which is poetic
sorry well please continue
on yeah so
i should
so yeah i should say i'm not a fan of
the current spin-off and it's partly
because there are so many better options
so my pick is and i think this is
probably a pretty popular one throughout
the internet uh is a
a prequel uh starring the young
marauders at school so that would be
james potter sirius black remus lupin
and peter pettigrew because three out of
those four uh are like legendarily
handsome people so it would be a
showcase for hot british actors and i'm
always down for that
but on a deeper level like we know so
little about them
and what we do know objectively rocks so
the four of them became illegal
animaguei during their time at school
which is almost impossible for wizards
their age to do and they created a
magical map that shows the whereabouts
of everyone at all times that can give
you full access to hogwarts and that's
all we know all we know is they did
those two things and we never get to see
it that sucks so i want to see them at
hogwarts you know lily and snape would
be like secondary characters and it
would just be those four
uh yeah i think but i would want to see
that as like a a mini series or tv
series i i think it would be too
i think putting it into movies as the
harry potter movies kind of proved like
you just jammed too much stuff in and it
gets too crowded so you think that so so
this would take place during their time
at school yeah and so what did the
marauders do i'm not i'm not really it
was that just their name for their
little clique i don't know yeah so when
they made the marauders map uh they gave
themselves uh nicknames and so peter
pettigrew was mooney no i'm sorry he was
wormtail whoa remus mooney i know i've
already screwed this up um
i mean you know why the nicknames are
the nicknames right i don't have to
explain right because they're animal
forms yes well i mean remus is a
werewolf so he's a werewolf yeah and
then wormtail is a rat and then prongs
is james and he's a i would have called
him wolfy
well maybe you should be a lot more
subtle yeah
and then um
so would you have called the serious
black uh doggy instead of padfoot
yes yeah
i would have called him buchi i would
have called him claw from black panther
great big sound gun arm guy though yeah
we've had this discussion yeah yeah yeah
i don't really trust you
i still i don't trust you to name things
so yeah i mean but they were also like
uh the like james and sirius in
particular were like really legendary
pranks or pranksters so it would be the
weasley twins but but bigger scale of
like funny pranks um so yeah i want a
prequel of young hot marauders at school
i just don't think this is too much to
ask it would do really well can i need
someone to make this and so i can forget
about fantastic beasts then and they'd
have different adventures on you know on
campus similar to the books or yeah i'm
sure you can come up with adventures
beyond what we already know which is a
weird magical
thing has invaded hogwarts and only the
marauders can solve it but can they get
an a in algebra it's not scooby-doo
right
well why not though
actually wait maybe they solve the
mystery of the week also
they legendarily don't teach any math at
hogwarts i don't understand how any kids
come out of that school prepared for any
semblance of the real world
i don't get it
they're like here turn this uh teacup
into a mouse but no math for you no
don't worry about math you don't know
the teacup mouse thing is more useful
for some reason
i mean it's one good way to stock up
your
your cabinets and get rid of your mouse
infestation exactly so yeah that's my
pick is it it's a young marauders
prequel series okay i like that i could
see that i would watch that yeah
tom what about you
i love that idea i'm a little i'm a
little hesitant to put something out
on the internet where nina says that she
wants to watch a bunch of hot 16 year
olds running around the school but like
uh i'm excited you know they'd be played
by people who are 35 that's how teenage
shows work that's a good they have every
faith yeah plus british people have
never been in the sun so like they age
everyone on riverdale is like old enough
to be my mother like let's let it go
i'm going to tell kj abba that you said
that
he's going to be texting him right now
my text messages you and kj are tight
me and kj okj rowling and uh
so uh yeah no i love that i uh
i think there's a ton of
cool characters that you could do stuff
with in the universe uh
i i was talking to somebody about this
last night and they actually pitched the
idea for a uh
arthur weasley travel show
like a
like a and i and i kind of love this
like the idea of like a steve style like
pbs just this guy he's just really
psyched about phones and plugs yeah
exactly because like exactly what you
were talking about like these are people
whose entire lives are an amusement park
of fantasy bananas like it's right it's
just this crazy stuff for them all the
time so then they go out and they see
postage stamps and they're like you lick
it and it sticks the thing and like if
you get to see this guy just looking at
the most mundane stuff in the world
with this sense of wonder in his eyes
especially if we brought back i can't
remember his name what was the name of
the actor that played arthur nina what
was the name of the actor who played
arthur mark something because he was
also in shakespeare in love uh and he
plays the guy with the stutter who does
the prologue well good news we're gonna
add his name yeah let's add on screen
mark's name because that's definitely
his first name
here
okay so now we know i would love to see
him he's fantastic
no he was great yeah he was really
charming in that and i think we can all
agree the adult cast of harry potter is
across the board really really well cast
and really good mm-hmm like every adult
actor is terrific great yeah
really really good they got helena
bonham carter to come in and play
yourself i thought that was great
[Laughter]
no it was wonderful i was always kind of
curious who michael caine
made enemies with that he was the only
british person that was not an idiot so
it was like just him and like michael
sheen and that's why michael sheen says
he did twilight is because he didn't get
to do harry potter
that makes sense yeah
i always kind of wondered about that and
then i thought the money spends the same
and they stopped one yeah
yeah
so yeah i think that that would be my
big my big pitch
that's so endearing that's so pure i
like that idea i love it
a little bit worried about nina's idea
also just because like
we're going to inevitably get the sad
boy snape episodes where he just stands
around in muted tones
staring at a girl that doesn't like him
writing poetry and calling himself a
half blood prince yeah
that just
that just
that's a little too close to home in
terms of
it's too it's too reflective of too many
high school experiences on this we don't
need this right yeah
no comment no no comment
yeah either that's fine sweet brian what
are your ideas man well i'm so glad that
you asked because i
came up with this idea 10 minutes ago
and now that i've done it
it's all i can think about
so
i don't know if you know but i am a big
fan of star trek
and i never wanted to say a word about
it so i know news to me i'm not actually
familiar with the show one of my
favorite
new
uh shows in the star trek universe is
lower decks where they spotlight the
people who make the ship run the ensigns
the lowly crewmen who do all the work
behind the scenes i'm really nervous
so my pitch for a harry potter spin-off
is an animated half-hour show called
hogwarts teacher's lounge
okay and god i thought you're going to
say something bad and worse okay good i
thought it was going to be the house
elves
there's too much there's too much i
don't want to touch that i don't know
let's not touch the house
in any sense well but i'm really nervous
to live by yeah i'm not unreleased can
you imagine that
six seasons of these like half-hearted
gollum impressions just like pouring
into a screen episode after episode it
wouldn't last it wouldn't last six
episodes
um it would last 10 years so right but
this hogwarts teachers lounge would be
exactly like what you were talking about
nina how
these students don't learn math so what
if you get it from the perspective of
hey the the ministry of magic is now
mandating that all hogwarts students
actually learn math so they import a
math teacher from nebraska
and he's he lives in hogwarts and i'm
sorry
you're pitching magical ted lasso and
i'm here for it i mean yeah this rock so
you mention it yeah i love it yeah he
has to kind of come to grips with the
fact that none of the people there are
licensed to teach whatsoever none of
them have teaching certificates um
there's murders happening at the school
frequently constantly nearly constantly
actually an annual basis yeah yeah the
children are surrounded by people who
can kill them
they had to they had to rebuild the
castle after a giant magical war erupted
there right and also there was a point
and there was also a point where a giant
snake was able to work its way through
the plumbing and everyone just went back
to school the next year as if that was a
totally normal thing to happen anywhere
even in a magic world yeah go to the pub
go to the public school nearby just
learn go anywhere go anywhere
so yeah
there so that's my pitch i want to see
what happens behind the scenes i want to
see what happens to the teachers i want
to see the teachers struggling to grade
all the papers and the papers are you
know like i don't know barfing pixie
dust or whatever happens in hogwarts i
have no idea um
like the weird interoffice politics that
comes from the fact that you know your
teachers are cons conscripting students
into magical armies on different sides
of good and evil and the fact that this
guy's just trying to teach his students
trigonometry like so that they're
prepared for when they eventually or
like when they have to balance a
checkbook you know there are like three
wizarding jobs and they're like magic
cop
magic doctor
i can't even think of a quidditch player
those are the only
shopkeepers there are four magical
wizard jobs and we just listed all of
them right exactly yeah i mean like does
what what's the what's the economic
system like do you remember the
breakdown of the money like isn't it
like 16 gallons i can't tell you how
many quiz oh answers i have flubbed
trying to remember the exact
same system
because they don't teach math nobody
decided to decimalize their currency so
what's it like when they eventually
right when they bring in an economics
teacher to teach everybody how to like
manage their money and how the the laws
of supply and demand work when scarcity
doesn't exist anymore in the magical way
will he teach them about like how credit
cards work because all of these people
deal in pure gold
this entire economic system
it's just gonna crash like the second
that he starts green shots will just
fall into the earth
that's my pitch that's what i want to
see i want to see hogwarts teachers
lounge i think it's a good idea yes
what's your question i love pitch i'm
really into it why does it have to be
animated and why could it not just be
created by bill lawrence and starring
jason sudeikis
i mean i guess it could be but my my
brain was animated my brain goes down
i'm going to say exact breath
exactly
no
i'm always talking about so i love ted
laughs though
the real answer is
is basically so that dumb stuff can
happen and that there aren't ah okay
without like expensive cgi that's that's
a good exactly you animate it you have
dumb things no that makes more castle
blow up everywhere maybe we can get
sudeikis as a voice actor
sure
i'm into it i'm really committed to this
now
so yeah that's my pick i love that great
idea thank you
and with hogwarts colon teachers lounge
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
video